welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of
invincible season 2 episode 2 titled in
about 6 hours I lose my virginity to a
fish this show continues to be one of
the best superhero adaptations on TV
right now so let's break it down for all
the Easter eggs animation details and
deeper layers of meaning that you might
have missed okay we open on graduation
day for the class of 2023 that's this
year at Reginald B Johnson High School B
Johnson himself is back voicing BN
Winslow the school's principal of course
sharing a Sur name with Carl Winslow his
character from Family Matters he says
for some of you it probably seemed like
this day would never come for others it
came far too quickly maybe you're even
wondering if you're ready for this for
what comes next you are yes Phil Johnson
says this when he looks out at the class
he sees a bright new world with a
special place for each and every one of
them but Mark is not sitting among the
subjects of that sentence again making
us worried about the fate of this
character like he might not be part of
this bright future he might be part of a
Darkest Timeline this episode's early
minutes reference to two Spider-Man
films the graduation day sequence of
2014's The Amazing Spider-Man 2 where
Andrew Garfield Peter Parker nearly
misses his graduation and GW Stacy's
valedictorian speech and of course 2017
Spider-Man homecoming where Tom Holland
Peter Parker foils a plot at the
Washington Monument doc seismic returns
from season 1 when he appeared at Mount
Rushmore he confirms that he is a doctor
not a professor because he never taught
he rants that this obscene phus is made
from Granite stolen from Earth isn't
them most
buildings you can keep the one made of
wood so I guess Lincoln's Log Cabin
totally okay the Washington Monument was
actually damaged and cracked by an
earthquake in 2011 so perhaps there was
a doc seismic from our world that was
trying to reclaim it as doc seisman
rides this giant Palace down we are
reminded of another Amazon Prime TV
superhero series with this kind of image
I am so sorry seismic revealed that
since falling in a pool of lava he made
friends with these magma Knights these
lava creatures first appeared in the
comics the packed Volume 2 number four
and then again Invincible number 36
seismic was a ruler of all of them now
magma being in their names makes less
sense now that they're above ground but
you know presumably that liquid rock is
buried beneath their Rocky skin so it's
still like underneath something Mark
kills the magma Knights and smashes
through the ground beneath the monument
punching up through the tip to uppercut
seismic and leaves that Monument have
submerged in the earth Bill Johnson says
as the great Abraham Lincoln once said
whatever you are be a good
one did he though yes this is a quote
often misattributed to Lincoln there is
no record of him ever saying that but
also remember that the immortal actually
is Abraham Lincoln according to the
flashback of his life from season 1 and
confirmed by Amazon Prime video so
someone ask him if he said this Mark
throws his graduation cap too high just
like he did with the garbage bag in
season one when he realized he first got
his powers B Johnson continues even
though the ceremony is over and everyone
threw their caps already be
bold be
original be yes we are back to cutting
to the title card in the middle of the
sentence whereas in season 1 the word
grew increasingly covered in blood
Episode by episode and last episode it
looked totally covered by the final
minutes it then switched to all red on
black with cracks forming through it
revealing blue so it looks like each
episode this season it's going to get
increasingly broken they kick back at
Eve's tree house which has more
decorations and personal touches and
last season like Christmas lights and
lots of flowers and plants Eve
manipulates pine cones into beer but
Mark does not partake as someone who's
been watching his mom slowly drink
herself to death I'm not surprised he's
staying away from anything alcoholic
will says Mark won't even take me flying
anymore boo his yeah in the comics will
was always bugging mark to take him
flying and to even let him try on his
Invincible costume at the USSA United
States space agency we were returned to
the Martian and seid subplot from season
1 it is the USSA here instead of NASA
but the logo is similar the mission crew
debit sending Invincible to Mars to try
to clear out all those seids Ben Schwarz
voices astronaut Russ Livingston who is
replaced by a shape-shifting martian his
Superior says one can blame you for
being a little
uh
uh not
yourself but it's yeah I love that final
little topole sound effect added in at
the end there Russ says I swear on my
three chambered heart just please do not
stab all three of them yes human hearts
have four chambers amphibians and most
reptiles have hearts with three chambers
so this makes Martian seem more similar
to those creatures than to humans alien
hearts and TV shows being the main thing
that can differentiate them from humans
is kind of a Trope in TV shows most
notably in Doctor Who like the doctor's
people the time Lords have two hearts
instead of one Adam Eve helps the
Chicago construction crew rebuil an
apartment complex that was destroyed by
omn man the forom says how do I know
that's to code this mom with a little
girl sticks up for Eve who uses our
powers to turn the empty lot next door
into a beautiful community park at Mark
and Debbie's house we see more of the
emotional aftermath that they've been
dealing with in season one these two
were super close and Debbie always knew
the right things to say to Mark when he
was struggling but now she cannot seem
to say anything right I think his close
connection to her might be what let him
keep his Humanity compared to the marks
in the other worlds like she's his
constant for this world and he's going
to need to keep trying to connect to her
to keep that part of himself open like
remember during their fight Nolan said
that biltrite DNA is so pure it meant
Mark was almost full vmite but we saw in
flashbacks that Debbie had a strong hand
in guiding Mark as he grew up so it's a
classic nature versus nurture debate
that's just so sad that Mark doesn't
want to go on one of these all-inclusive
resort vacations with his mom because
you know what all-inclusive means it
means the alcohol's covered after Cecil
had their house rebuilt there's been one
faulty cabinet that won't stay closed
and here we see it pop back open one
last time after Mark leaves as if
punctuate that everything has been off
with them since the events of the season
1 finale the new Guardians of the globe
are continuing their training under the
leadership of the immortal and they look
like they have been struggling in Rex's
Locker we see a folded up costume a
burger container and two different kinds
of grenades Rex finds duplicate in the
locker room showers mirroring the season
1 episode when Eve discovered that he
was cheating on her with duplicate this
time duplicate is hooking up with the
Immortals so the tables have turned I
love that she went from Rex the most
immature member of the team to the most
mature member of the team the The
Immortal is over a thousand years old so
you know there's just a bit of an age
Gap there Rex got to hook up with three
duplicates in his shower scene in season
1 but here the immortal gets four of
them which you know has just got to
drive Rex extra crazy at his apartment
the marshan posing as the astronaut Russ
clearly hasn't been watering the house
plant probably because he lived on a
desert planet and he didn't even know he
needed to water this thing he has a
whole freezer full of Alonso Super Pizza
which he eats still frozen he watches a
special on TV about Martian Man Who was
exiled from Mars for some unknown reason
when the newscast talks about the heroic
Deeds Martian Man performed Russ reverts
to his true form and smiles like he's
proud this is probably what gives him
the idea to try to join up with the
Guardians of the globe later in the
episode as he flies over a burger Mart
Mark looks down wistfully at a bunch of
teens eating and laughing Cecil is
sending him to Midnight City which was
cursed by the midnight magician to be
locked in Perpetual midnight we saw this
city in the season 1 Premiere when
Darkwing captured two criminals and left
them magnetically handcuffed to some
metal tubes on the top of a building at
the time he told them that he'd be back
for them the next day but since he was
murdered shortly after and day is kind
of hard to come by here we now see their
skeletal corpses here they're wearing
the tattered remains of the same clothes
they had on when we last saw them night
boy dark Wing's assistant has taken up
the mantle of dark wi 2 since the
original's death he's kind of like the
robin to dark WIS Batman and since he
claims he's hearing voices he clearly is
not doing okay Invincible says come on
man dark queen was at my 12th birthday
party so I'm pretty sure he doesn't kill
people this could be a commentary on how
the SN version of Batman killed people
and it was a really divisive decision oh
one shot energy huh I think I'll try
it so what is one shot Focus sh
do see
[Music]
it eternity
wa so uh one shot really is all you need
begin your transformation with oneshot
energy today by going to oneshot
energy.com neww rockstars for 10% off
your order Darkwing 2 pushes Invincible
into the shadow verse and this is all
taken directly from the comics in the
comics night boy took up the mantle
after Darkwing died but cracked under
the pressure and killed anyone in the
city who was committing even Petty
crimes he had the ability to access an
alternate Dimension that he called The
Shadow verse which touches on our
Dimension only in places of extreme
Darkness Darkwing got imprisoned after
Invincible took him in but ceso went to
him and offered him a pardon if he went
to work for him in the global Defense
Agency there is a sign that reads simper
vigilans which means always Vigilant or
always ready in Latin Debbie is
surprised to see Donald there because
she watched him die Donald doesn't seem
to know why she's surprised and even
mutters I wonder what that was all about
so yes this is very similar to Coulson
and agent of shield not remembering how
he was revived after Loki killed him in
the 2012 Avengers film later on this
episode Donald presses Cecil on why
Debbie was acting the the way she was
but Cecil isn't giving anything up Eve
talks to her mom who reveals that they
have been having financial troubles Eve
creates a bunch of food for them but her
dad is as usual dickish self he's been
working at Burger Mart ever since the
corporate office for the furniture store
he worked for for 20 years was destroyed
in the omn man battle he uses that event
to justify his bigotry toward all
powered people including Eve and he even
refers to Eve and others as you people
like damn dude we see Amber volunteering
at the soup kitchen that she volunteered
at in season 1 and she's multitasking
making calls for the ktie Giles comp
troller campaign Mike flies her to Las
Vegas for lunch but he has to cut it
short when he's summon Away by Cecil now
that Amber knows the truth about Mark
being Invincible she's super
understanding about all of it proving
that he probably should have been honest
with her from the start she was only
pissed about it all in season 1 because
she didn't know why he kept standing her
up and once she figured out what was
going on she was mad that he lied to her
for so long Cecil tells Mark that the
atlantans are pissed that his dad killed
aquaris their King according to custom
Mark needs to marry the King's widow
Aquaria to smooth things over the super
villain group The Lizard leag from
season one is back and this time they
hit a bio research lab outside of Dallas
their leader King Lizard is in prison
but Supreme lizard rose up to take his
place so the lizard league is based off
of Cobra from GI Joe and if King Lizard
was based off of Cobra Commander Supreme
lizard is clearly based off of serpent
who had a power struggle with Cobra
Commander and was made in a lab from the
DNA of every World Conqueror and leader
throughout history Supreme lizard's
costume design looks really similar to
serpentor with the snakehead in the cape
Rex Spode punches Supreme lizard but
it's not the X weo who says
Nope not this again I'm not
doing another
me that me better not be you Rudy in
season 1 robot Rudy used Rex's DNA to
clone him in a younger form and
transferred OG to formed Rudy's
Consciousness into that body so that he
could be with monster girl in a more
appealing form to her Rex was not
pleased about this the new Rex reveals
himself to this shapes Smith who is
actually Martian Russ who wants to
enlist with the team underwater Mark
meets Queen Aquarius voiced by Tatiana
masani the actress who played She-Hulk
in the MCU she tells him that he's
mistaken about why he's there why would
I need a king I commanded this Kingdom
for a decade while Aquarius played dress
up with you humans in season one when
omn man summoned the Guardians of the
globe right before killing them Aquarius
was shown in his underwater home and he
was super bored and when this alert went
off when he was needed he whooped and
cheered so clearly he didn't really
enjoy life down there now it all makes
sense why his wife was the one actually
running things there's this hilarious
moment where the queen explains to mark
that they did away with this barbaric
custom of forcing someone to marry and
replaced it with the new custom of trial
by combat as Mark waits for the creature
he's supposed to fight it totally
reminded me of 1981's Clash of the
Titans release the Kraken scene release
the Kraken release the death dweller and
then we get this great fake out where
Mark thinks he's going to be fighting a
cute tiny creature but it's attached to
a much larger monster this is like a
deep sea angler fish which uses a
rodlike protrusion on its head to lure
and prey before eating it Debbie is back
at work trying to sell a house and this
mailbox door won't stay shut just like
her cabinet door at home she gets
totally triggered by this husband who's
a total dick she's not your pet Debbie
heard Nolan refer to her as more of a
pet and she understandably hasn't
recovered this guy even has gray hair
around his temples just like Nolan does
after Mark fights his creature it lets
out a scream that actually hurts Mark
later Cecil tells Donald to give the
audio to the boys in R&D so I'm guessing
he's going to turn that sound into a
kind of Sonic weapon similar to the
weapons used against the soups and the
boys and gen v he's got to be ready in
case omn man comes back or if Mark ever
goes Rogue Eve's dad threw away all the
food she created for him and for her mom
and even threw away the solid gold Apple
she created so he could sell it instead
of working a minimum wage job during
their argument he reveals that the
community park she created collapse the
headline on the newspaper he shows her
reads superhero sink hold we see a photo
of the little girl from earlier and her
mom who stuck up for Eve indicating that
they were among the ones hurt now at
Debbie and marks there are these wooden
ducks with pink and blue ribbons on the
bills these could be Korean wedding
ducks that were given to Debbie and
Nolan at their wedding these are
customarily a symbol of love Fidelity
and peace so I'm assuming Debbie has
been getting drunk and taking a trip
down memory lane which is never a good
idea but especially not when you've
recently discovered that your husband
wants to conquer your planet Debbie goes
for more wine and that faulty cabinet
door finally makes her crack Mark comes
home to find her crying on the floor
among glass and other debris and they
finally hug which hopefully means they
can start to heal their bond this shapes
Smith gives the Guardians of the globe
the most generic superhero backstory
with zero personal details I was born a
baby human right here on the planet of
Earth as he talks his story is intercut
with seeds of what happened to the real
Russ who got taken over by seids and is
still on Mars as the seids tried to take
it over back at lizard leaks
headquarters the Supreme lizard is
giving a rallying speech before he is
killed by King Lizard and I just love
how Supreme lizard's voice is deep and
graval just like serpentor who was
voiced by dick aier in the GI Jo film
you will do as I say or I shall burn
your nation to the ground we are the
lizard league and we are unstoppable and
alternatively King Lizard has a high
shrieky voice like Cobra Commander who
is voiced by Chris L superb now we must
press our advantage if anyone is going
to turn this organization around it's
going to be king lizard just see
attention to detail in this homage is so
great we cut to the Pentagon with a sign
that says parking in front which is both
hilarious and serves to let us know that
we are in a different Universe than the
one that we are used to since a sign
usually reads parking in rear alternate
Dimension Mark is being interrogated by
angstrom Levy about how his dad was
defeated and he was captured they're
interrupted by what seems like a female
Cecil and a female Donald and Levy exits
through a portal telling them to make
him pay for what he did to your
world please subscribe to all three
channels of the new rock stars Network
and hey we're doing a live show this
Thursday November 16th at brain dead
studios in Los Angeles if you're in the
LA area it's going to be a lot of fun
come hang out with us grab one of these
we're all going to die shirts inspired
by at nerd. shop follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at eaos follow new rockstars
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis everything you love thanks for
watching
[Music]
bye